[Musique]
on se retrouve une dernière fois autour
de cette table pour évoquer le noël des
animaux à présent eux aussi fait noël
avec la spa chaque année à un événement
d'envergure se déroule à paris place de
la république avec la mobilisation des
gilet jaune cette année là espère est
due à l'annuler elle a demandé à tous
ceux qui avaient un projet d'adoption de
se rendre dans les refuges directement
nous sommes allés à plaisir pour
rencontrer les bénévoles les salariés
qui oeuvrent écouter marie-laure carmes
la responsable le but de la spa c'est
que l'adoption soit une adoption
responsable réfléchit donc on a on a
l'habitude de poser toujours les mêmes
questions qui nous permettent de cibler
l'importance de l'adoption et de la
projeter aussi sûr sûr sûr le futur on
leur parle bien sûr des vacances parce
que il ya toujours le prennent des
vacances que faire pendant les vacances
quand on a un animal
donc voilà dans cette période là on fait
très attention mais le reste de l'année
aussi l'aspect acquis rappelle tout de
même qu offrir un animal à noël se pense
en amont c'est un engagement au
quotidien hors de question de les
abandonner à nouveau on s'en doute pour
le week end d'adoption à noël cette
année 967 animaux ont trouvé une
nouvelle la famille en france et il en
reste encore vous êtes plutôt chiens
chats chiens chats chiens chiens et
chats h alors un chat je vous présente
elton regarder il cherche une famille
locale talent qu'on a appris à connaître
ses besoins donc c'est un chat qui est
vif extrêmement présent et donc qui aura
certainement besoin plutôt de vivre en
pavillon ça c'est très important
les nombreux chats qui ne s'adaptent pas
la vie en appartement et c'est souvent
une raison d'abandon donc nous
effectivement l'idée c'est vraiment
d'adopter dû faire une adoption
responsable sur le long terme avec le
moins de risque de retour possible
elton vous a séduit il est mignon pour
le côté peut-être qu'il va trouver une
nouvelle une nouvelle famille et pour
ceux qui préfèrent les chiens j'en ai un
petit dernier lui aussi attend
impatiemment une famille et il n'a pas
eu un parcours facile parce que à la spa
aussi il ya des urgences des sos comme
ils appellent pour ces animaux un
pinscher cette fois-ci regardez c'est
une petite chaîne qui à peu près huit
ans une pinscher qui arrivé au refuge il
ya quelques mois déjà
elles étaient obèses c'est une petite
chaîne qui avait aucune contrainte qui
devait vivre avec une personne âgée et
on a eu beaucoup de mal à faire à le
faire prendre confiance en nous elle
était extrêmement hargneuse agressive un
petit peu tous goûtés refuge et petit à
petit elle prend ses habitudes
alors l'idée c'est pâques a fini ses
jours on refuse parce que c'est une
petit est très rigolote qui est
extrêmement intelligente
le prince et qu'elle a une très mauvaise
façon de se présenter aux adoptants tout
ce qu'elle connaît pas elle va d'office
se montrait hargneuse et c'est une
petite chienne qu'on ne passera pas avec
des jeunes enfants parce qu'elle peut
pincer
donc il faut des connaisseurs du
pinscher parce que lépine sur la de base
sont des chiens à forte personnalité et
comment se passe une adoption
quels sont les papilles et les
responsabilités que vous aurez lorsque
vous vous présenter marie-laure caron à
nouveau quand on vient dans un refuge
ont fait remplir un petit document qui
nous permet de savoir dans quelles
conditions vivra le chien ou le chat
pour cibler en fait au mieux possible
l'animal qui peut intéresser les gens
puisque le but en fait c'est de trouver
l'animal qui va correspondre aux besoins
et
vice versa à la famille et donc on
demande une participation de 250 euros
pour l'adoption d'un chien 300 euros
pour un chiot et 150 euros pour un chat
ils sont identifiés vaccinés stérilisés
et si vous voulez adopter vous pouvez
contacter le centre de plaisir où
quelques-uns des 62 autres refuges sur
la totalité de l'année 2010 est 38000
adoption se sont déroulés c'est bien
mais le meilleur moyen bien évidemment
de ne pas te faire souffrir ses animaux
c'est de ne pas les abandonner de
réfléchir avant vous avez des animaux
chacun chacune oui un chien un chien
yorkshire qui s'appelle uno uno michael
il est déjà venu à la rédaction la dg
voilà j'ai un petit chez un petit carlin
mais je lui ai donné à mes parents parce
qu'ils avaient un grand jardin et en
appartement donc je vais le voir c'est
un peu la garde alternée enfin quand ils
partent en vacances à cet égard dallaire
ainsi de suite voilà et il s'appelle
fini fini quand même y ait une paille
comme un gardien non encore très bien
[Musique]